hello everybody my name is paul scott
and i'm a research geneticist in the
usda ars and together with my co-host dr
thomas luberstedt from the iowa state
university department of agronomy i'm
pleased to invite you to the national
association of plant breeders meeting in
2022 which will be held
august 8th to 11th
in ames iowa
the most exciting thing about this
meeting for us is that we are
tentatively planning to hold it in
person
of course you know iowa is centrally
located
and it's closer than you think
there are more than 30 direct flights to
des moines international airport
the venue of the conference will be the
sheman building which is the conference
center
adjacent to the campus of iowa state
university
ames is a small town and it's easy to
get around there's
good public transportation and we'll be
running a shuttle from the conference
hotel to the sheman building but if you
prefer to stretch your legs it's a 37
minute walk
that goes by the scenic
reiman gardens and the jack tri stadium
we're still finalizing our
pre-conference tours but
there are many opportunities in the ames
area and i'm sure you'll be pleased with
what we come up with
the theme of the meeting is past present
and future of plant breeding
the past is represented by a celebration
of the 100th anniversary of
the federal state corn breeding program
in iowa
the present is shown
in in this picture
of the plant breeding faculty and
students at iowa state university many
of these people are helping to organize
the meeting
and of course we don't know what the
future of plant breeding holds but if
the activity at iowa state university is
any indication
it will involve
more interaction with engineers to
design new processes and technology to
increase the efficiency of plant
breeding
anybody who comes to iowa expects to see
corn and soybean breeding and you won't
be disappointed
but we think you'll be surprised at what
corn and soybean breeding looks like
today
and at the diversity of crops that are
bred in the ames area including cover
crops sorghum mung bean sunflower and
even marigold
you'll have an opportunity to tour the
north central regional plant
introduction station which is home of a
maze germplasm collection with 36 000
accessions as well as germplasm
collections for sunflower flax cucurbitz
carrots amaranth and many other crops
you'll have a chance to tour the iowa
state university agronomy farm including
the doubled haploid facility for maize
see you in ames